notre correspondante fanny chauvin
bonjour à vous fanny pouvez-vous d'abord
nous expliquer en quoi consiste cette
réunion donc la dixième depuis le début
de ce conflit en ukraine
et bien cette réunion a été convoquée
hier soir par moscou car la russie
accuse de nouveau l'ukraine de détenir
des armes bactériologiques
le représentant de la russie à l'onu d'y
avoir de nouvelles preuves de deux 2
nouveaux documents qui montrerait que
des laboratoires
travaillerez sur la transmission de
maladies des animaux aux humains en
ukraine ces laboratoires toujours selon
as russie serait financé par les etats
unis acquis kiev aurait donné je cite
carte blanche pour ses expériences alors
les etats unis ont dénoncé des théories
conspirationnistes venu tout droit du
dark web pour les occidentaux la russie
cherche à détourner l'attention de ses
crimes c'est une campagne de
désinformation un prétexte pour
l'ambassadeur français dont le but
serait de justifier une escalade
militaire et peut-être l'utilisation de
ces armes bactériologiques en ukraine le
représentant de la france à l'onu qui a
aussi rappelé que la russie avait
utilisé ces armes déjà en syrie et
qu'elle avait et a mentionné un
l'empoisonnement de l'opposant un
politique alexis navalni quant à la
chine lors de cette réunion pékin a
rappelé sa volonté d'un cessez-le-feu et
elle s'est dit prête à faciliter le
dialogue entre la russie et l entre la
russie et l'ukraine concernant les
accusations de moscou la chine demandent
des réponses aux parties concernées
c'est-à-dire aux états unis enfin notez
qu'à la fin de la réunion l'ambassadeur
russe a repris la parole cette fois ci
sans notes il a contre attaqué il a
dénoncé le cynisme des occidentaux qui
n'auraient pas écouté ses arguments
fanny chauffin en direct de new york
pour france24 merci à vous fanni